I was actually bored bro I ain't gonna
lie like when I came up with this piece
I think I had just recently seen like uh
Drake had popped out with like the
Pharrell piece um I gotta do some iconic
like that you feel me yo where my phone
at wrong let me see my phone I'm gonna
show you how I came up with this girl I
actually had to try to edit this myself
I'm like everybody don't do the Marvel
and DC together you feel me so I'm like
I'm gonna do something different that's
gonna have people talk how you feel me
that's just me Joker guy be the main
drone cause he like he stand out the
most I fly out of everybody but black
panther I had to put the Black Panther
on there at the represent you know
Superman I always with Superman you
feeling me I don't see these hoes though
but you know I knew Spider-Man just was
gonna look good on that chain you feel
me but yeah everybody like bro you can't
do this you can't do that I do what I
want bro